[MUSIC]
I don't intend to apologize
But if you had taken a different approach, this wouldn't have happened.You
should be happy in the human world.
Lars Erase all bad memories and
go
I'll have Master Tsubasu and my energy erased
Is there anything good to remember?
I
think it's hell here I
was fed to the brim and was given a decent job
I was born and raised in a small village
Even life there was hard
Even if I plow,
most of the harvested crops are taken away by the lord, and there is almost nothing left for my own
mouth.
You might die. If you're going to die in the
bathtub, then you
're just going to die there. How did you resign early?
I'd like Ainz to take you to Tour Nazarick.
I don't have any, but I do have a little desire to see my sister, but
my feelings of not wanting to reveal and remember are stronger
.
[
Music
]